hello Anna welcome back to the Leia hail
plan show so joining me today is a man
who some might call the real life Bruce
Wayne he helps meditate in that
Hollywood muscular physique and he has
six best-selling fitness programs called
Kino body now before I bring him on the
show please don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe if you like this
kind of content because I'm going to be
making a lot more of it grego Gallagher
welcome to the show how are you I'm
great I just flew into Miami last night
I'm excited to be here I've been
checking out your stuff you're freaking
blowing up it's insane thank you so much
well it's so good to have you here like
Miami suits you you've already got a bit
of a tan going on Miami suits me well I
love it here
um I first came out here like last year
for like a few months and it's just like
it's Heaven it's like leaving Canada
feels great yeah absolutely Canada is is
a it's not a great place actually but
we'll get into all of that we'll get
into all those restrictions in a bit but
I've been following a lot of your
content you talk about um you know male
self-improvement fitness men's
testosterone and we're gonna get into
all of that but one thing that I have
noticed is this comparison to Batman and
Bruce Wayne so I want to try and
understand like where did that come from
and have you had some kind of like
Batman transformation so okay this like
started when I was six years old okay I
had like a Batman action figure and I
asked my dad I'm like hey like can I
ever look like this I want to have that
strength and power and that's when I
first realized my father told me he's
like yeah you can you just gotta work
out and eat right and that was like when
the seed was planted we all have this
amazing gift we have the power to train
to eat right to gain muscle to feel
better to be healthier and so few of us
really take advantage of that and so
that that's where the seed planted and
then years and years later there wasn't
really a fitness approach that inspired
me that was working out for
um like different sports for athletes
there was weight loss There Was You Know
CrossFit and then there was of course
like bodybuilding but nothing really
spoke to me so I kind of felt
disenfranchised and the realization was
like you know you watch a movie with
Brad Pitt and Troy or you see Christian
Bale get ready for Batman it's like
that's what I want I want to look like
the movie star and have that strength
and power and as opposed to just being a
bodybuilder and putting on tons of size
and you know being 220 pounds I wanted
that movie star look yeah it's such an
interesting thing because a lot of
people always trying to get that
bodybuilder shape and I don't think many
people like that other than that
particular Niche um so I want to
understand how all of this started but
before we do you you had this marketing
degree you you're in University and I
heard you say
um oh I read that it was useless like
those were your words you said it was
useless so how did you get into fitness
and content and social media take me
back to the very beginning yeah so
I went to University when I was 18 years
old in Canada and I did a marketing
management program and initially I kind
of was on the fence about school I
didn't really it didn't really seem like
the path for me to become very very
successful
um but I just did it anyway I'm like you
know what let's give it a shot and I
went to class and I just never really
felt inspired the thing about me is for
me to like really like access my highest
level of intelligence I have to feel
very incentivized and in school I never
felt that incentive you know parents and
people will tell you you need the degree
you need the degree I'm like why if I'm
gonna start a business why do I need the
degree so it's more about like the
degree the piece of paper than the
actual education I want to get the
absolute best education to achieve my
goals and I never once really felt like
that resided within University I felt
like you know in 2009 2010 even years
prior so much was happening on the
internet I could learn pretty much
everything I needed to learn on the
internet and also
um the world was changing so fast as far
as social media and blogging and and
building websites everything was
changing so fast the university couldn't
keep up so I'm like you know what I am
gonna you know kind of Go My Own
Direction understand all this different
all these different marketing things
online and really figure it out but
funny enough all of the marketing that
I've learned has been more or less
common sense for me
it has been
what do I like what would work on me
what do I think is cool and when you
actually focus on not like what's going
to sell a customer what would I actually
want what would excite and inspire me
that's when you can really access like
your highest level like genius when
you're really thinking about like what
is going to make me excited
um and I I can't tell you how happy I
was to just leave school behind at 18 19
years old being in class and learning
stuff and like you know 89 90 of it like
you're just doing to get your marks and
get your piece of paper you're not
actually like oh my God this is amazing
look at what like you know and doing
exams just uh it's so much more fun to
actually build something and spend spend
years and years in school were you like
terrified to drop out did you have any
doubt no I I had zero doubt I had zero I
was
I was so happy to drop out it's funny
like I had this very very absolute
strong sense of certainty in myself and
confidence almost looking back I'm like
was there a little bit of delusion there
but there was like zero doubt in my mind
I was absolutely dialed in I saw the
path now initially my goal wasn't to
make a ton of money and build a massive
business my goal was to a do what I love
and like support myself and have freedom
and if I did all those three that was a
win for me
um and then things end up becoming a lot
bigger than I actually expected oh you
need that level of delusion that's right
that's what I'm hearing and people often
laugh at people for being delusional but
I think that's the only way you're ever
gonna get anywhere yeah and you know it
was it was like some level of delusion
but I wasn't telling myself oh I'm gonna
build a 100 million dollar company with
nothing to show for it because I see
some people kind of have like a little
bit they they have these insane crazy
goals and there's really no path for
them to get there it's better to like
set like that first strong powerful goal
you can get to
um but then have like have a bit of
delusion in and of that and so yeah for
me it was like well you know what like I
know like I know I can build like a
six-figure business that's no question
about it and then once you get to that
level then you go for the next the next
to the next and that's kind of where I
find I get the most motivated and I find
that my self-belief really really kicks
in and a lot of the stuff that you talk
about is men's testosterone so I want to
get I want to get into that I want to
understand because it's a really hot
topic online and it's a Hot Topic in
society in general and I want to
understand what is testosterone and why
is it important for a man and before you
answer Andrew Tate said when I
interviewed him he said that it's a
man's superpower and I think that's a
really interesting way to explain it so
what is men's testosterone and why is it
important yes so testosterone is
essentially men and women both have
testosterone but the at like the a man
has 10 times more testosterone uh than a
female and it's really your androgenic
hormone it Powers muscle building all of
the characteristics that are associated
with being a man and masculine are
really built off of testosterone and men
having 10 times more than females so our
ability to put on muscle
um our higher levels of ambition
um etc etc and crazy enough right right
crazy enough
um male testosterone levels are a lot
lower now than they were even in 1999 in
the 80s they're dropping and it's very
very alarming and we're not even seeing
a downturn we're not even seeing a
plateau like it's been dropping steadily
without any Plateau so who knows where
it's going to be in another 10 20 30
um years but you know as a man like one
of the one of the things that happens as
you go through puberty you get this
increase in testosterone you put on more
muscle you get a deeper voice
etc etc and uh and it's a scary thing
for men to lose their testosterone
because it's not just like that element
of masculinity it's also important as a
man for confidence
um for you know anxiety depression when
sauce and levels are low you see higher
like increases in anxiety and depression
um so it's pretty it's pretty important
um and even testosterone in men can help
keep you calm under stressful situations
that's actually a sign of having higher
testosterone is that when [__] is
essentially hitting the fan you can
actually remain cool whereas you know if
you're testosterone levels are lower you
can be more reactive and it's also kind
of it actually
um relates to for example police
officers that are trained in hand-hand
combat actually get into less uh
physical acts of you know like less
physical situations than those that are
not trained for example because when
you're trained in martial arts and then
someone's in your face you can remain
calm because you know what to do you
know how to handle the situation whereas
if you don't have that confidence you're
more likely to use excessive force or to
react incorrectly and so same thing when
you have higher testosterone there's a
certain confidence that you have under
very uh stressful situations
so why is it declining and
um why is that a bad thing and then also
actually answer this and then I'll ask
my third question
so there's not like a 1 000 clear-cut
reason why uh it's declining like no one
has the 100 crystal ball here is exactly
why it's declining
um there are certain factors that come
into play
um so one of them is as humans and as
people become less active and gain body
fat we see a drop in testosterone so for
example
um a guy that has you know a 40 inch
waist on average is gonna have much
lower testosterone than a guy with a 32
inch waist your waistline is inversely
correlated with testosterone now that is
one aspect but even controlling for body
fat we are still seeing a massive drop
in testosterone and so there's other
aspects at play
um one of them is you know right now
people are probably watching this and
they probably have like they're watching
this on the computer they probably have
their phone in their pocket okay okay uh
and that's going to emit radiation that
the more the more time you have your
phone in your pocket mine's in my pocket
right now but I'm in airplane mode uh
the the more exposure of radiation close
to your you know Family Jewels the lower
testosterone levels are um we're also
seeing higher amounts of uh uh estrogens
in in plastic like we're basically those
estrogens and Plastics
um we're seeing phthalates different
compounds that are making their way into
food there's all of these different
endocrine disrupting chemicals that
we're exposing to that were in a much
lesser extent decades and decades ago so
we have more of these whole and
disrupting chemicals
um coming into our body and then that
can disrupt your body's own ability to
produce testosterone and I'm seeing it
because I have you know I have family
members friends and they'll go get their
blood work done and they'll show me
their numbers I have many different
people that um send me their blood work
especially before they you know uh take
my mojo and it is it is we're seeing
like pretty like they're pretty low
these levels
um so for example like you know in the
80s it was normal for a guy to be around
seven eight hundred uh testosterone
nanograms per desk leader now a lot of
guys that get checked they're kind of in
the 400s you know maybe 500s um and then
some of the guys that have maybe they're
in seven eight hundreds uh they get
their free checked and they're free
testosterone is not even that high
because most of their testosterone's
bound up and they're not able to
actually utilize as much of the free
um so it's pretty it's pretty alarming
correct me if I'm wrong I I saw that
doctors have now lowered the standard of
what's okay and what's normal so if a
man so what would be what would we what
would be regarded as low testosterone
back in the 60s is now regarded as
normal right right it's that and also
like the thing is is that if you're a 25
year old even a 35 year old they are
putting you in the same category as a 75
80 year old for wow so you could you
know if you're 25 and you're
testosterone levels checked and they're
380 390 the doctor will say you're
perfectly healthy yeah whereas if you're
75 year old and you're 380 390 it's the
same thing so there should be some
separation between you know men that are
you know in their 20s and 30s and Men
there are in their 60s and 70s as a man
if you're 25 30 and your testosterone
levels are 400 380 that's not where you
want to be sure you know the doctor will
tell you you're fine you know not a big
issue but if you're trying to be
absolutely as optimal as possible you're
not going to be performing be you're not
going to be performing at the highest
level at those levels so how do you
increase your testosterone so there's
different ways you can increase uh your
body's ability to produce testosterone
um now you know it's important to
mention that some people can damage
their body very badly where they can't
actually get it up unfortunately so
um for example you know I had a friend
that had a really really bad concussion
um and his body stopped producing
testosterone wow wow um and so his
levels were really low like sub 300 200
and he definitely tried to kind of get
it up um now that's not like that's not
normal that you just get a concussion
your body shuts down but it can happen
um another guy I know was an athlete as
a teenager and his his coach had them
all the kids pumping steroids at 14 15.
when your body's just developing and
that can crush your body's ability to
produce testosterones he can't eat so
he's had a very very hard time getting
his uh getting his levels up and he's
actually on trt so you know if we avoid
like those extreme cases which are you
know more of an anomaly
um there's certain ways you can get your
body's testosterone up
um of course the first thing you have to
do is get good sleep sleep is very very
important vitamin D
um lifting lifting is very very
important to do you know a few days a
week
um and you know if you're doing tons and
tons of cardio Marathon running not as
good I know some guys love biking and
cycling but that but like it's been
shown that when you're biking for hours
a day it actually reduces your
testosterone lowers your sperm count
higher rates of erectile dysfunction
because of the pressure
um yep so that definitely uh is not as
good but intense intense uh lifting
sprinting some brisk walking is like the
key exercise for your body to produce
more testosterone
um as well like nutrition
um and maintaining a lean body uh
getting in the right amount of minerals
like zinc magnesium Boron very very
important
um and as well there are certain things
like there's certain things you can do
to increase testosterone there's also
certain things that can hurt your body
your body's ability to produce
testosterone so wearing a lot of cologne
a lot of scented products that's the
body wash yeah oh wow you're literally
you're literally putting inside your
skin because your skin is the largest
largest organ on your body and it
absorbs everything you put in it you're
literally putting in endocrine
disruptors into your body is that the
same for men and women like so wait so
you never wear aftershave you think
that's bad I don't wear it so even
here's the funny thing for a woman if
they're exposed to too many phthalates
um what's that it's like a it's a
chemical that's sort of used to like
prolong a scent so if you have like you
have like a body wash you have like some
scented detergent in order for the scent
to not just go away after 20 30 minutes
they use phthalates to sort of extend
the scent but so here's the unfortunate
thing let's say a woman's wearing lots
of that stuff yeah sure maybe it's not
going to affect you because you're not
going to like testosterone might not be
as important to have at that higher
level
um that said if you're pregnant and your
baby gets exposed to too many phthalates
um It's associated with being born with
a much smaller penis wow wow well so wow
I wouldn't do that to my son yeah but
I'm pregnant no wine and no perfume yeah
exactly so uh but it's in everything and
a lot of people just are loading on body
wash every single day all of these very
strong chemicals and I don't I don't
wear any any sort of artificial
ingredients artificial fragrances
um so what do you wear like just freshen
or nothing I shower and I have like some
sort of like natural uh deodorant and uh
if you take care of your health you
should naturally smell good right you
should naturally smell like you know
good so the idea that you have to like
put on you know lots of cologne all the
time is is not uh it's not a good sign
that's interesting yeah that's
interesting I do know people who do just
smell you know and you know what's funny
like if you're really really attracted
to someone they smell amazing they smell
amazing like their natural scent is is
like the most amazing
um not like you know so that's that's
sort of my recommendation
um but the absolute worst culprit even
if you want to wear a bit of cologne
even if you want to have like a certain
deodorant that you like the worst
culprit is going to be like the body
wash
the body wash you're rubbing all into
your skin at least use something natural
there
um as well as a lot of the certain
laundry detergents that are scented
um have the highest load of phthalates
so those two are the simplest to cut out
and then also like you know I I see some
people wear just so much perfume so much
cologne it's like like relax okay we
have Pokemon right now no no it's
perfect
subtle no no yours
no no yours is perfect don't worry don't
worry you know it's very very subtle
like you you know the perfect amount but
some people walk into a room yeah 15
feet away yeah I hate that I was
actually at dinner in Toronto with a you
know a buddy that works for me and then
we're at dinner there's a couple like
there's a couple over there and we were
like trying to enjoy our wine and steak
and I was like I'm tasting this freaking
they're scent like easy yeah yeah I know
that's crazy but most people don't know
that it's actually not great for you I
didn't know that yeah can you ever have
too much testosterone like I've powder
can cause hair loss I've also heard this
isn't really testosterone but I heard
them well no I was going to say like
um if you lift weights when you're young
that can like stunt your growth like
there's all these messes yeah yes let's
focus on uh the first one right
um so can you have too much testosterone
I've rarely ever seen anyone that
naturally had too much testosterone it
is really really really hard I have yet
to see someone that naturally had has
too much testosterone now what you will
see is guys that go on anabolics
steroids and they take you know uh you
know they take bodybuilding doses they
are short in their lifespan they're
getting and they're causing tons and
tons of issues and hair loss acne those
are more superficial but they literally
are accelerating aging you see guys that
shoot up lots of steroids in their 20s
by the time they're my age by the time
they're 31 they look like they're 45.
you look young for 31 by the way you
look more like 28. okay yeah three years
okay but that's good because that will
get longer that that Gap will stretch as
you get older yeah but I haven't I
haven't seen one single person that was
not on any drugs whose like testosterone
was too high
um for a guy to have very high
testosterone uh it would probably be
like 1200 nanograms per deciliter as the
total and free would be you know high
20s and and that that is like if if
you're in that level naturally
um you're gonna like be feeling pretty
good now when you take anabolic steroids
and you're taking high high amounts then
you see some of that those uh side
effects where you have uh mood swings
maybe you have this heightened temper
you're more reactive
um that's when things can get really
really messy when you're pumping in way
too much but then like a bunch of
cascading effects happen when you're
putting in synthetic testosterone in
your body in very high amounts then
different hormones get out of whack
estrogen shoots up and you see even guys
that get little fat deposits in there in
their nipples because their whole body
is having this cascading you know
certain effects so that that's trt
um TR so trt is more more like
sublimated for men whose levels are very
low and then they they try and take trt
to kind of get to like where they should
be naturally or the higher end of
natural that would be uh men that are
taking like legit bodybuilding doses
um if you see some of these guys they're
getting exposed recently for their for
their different doses a lot of times hey
leverking a lot of times and funny
enough his his testosterone dose was
apparently wasn't that high but a lot of
times these guys are combining many
different compounds it's not just
they're taking testosterone they're
taking many different types of steroids
insulin and then it just the list goes
on and that's and we're seeing it you
know there was like this idea that was
trying to those people were trying to
put out like a decade or two ago like oh
like you know steroids are completely
safe it's one of the safest things you
know uh that that you can do no one's
dying from it and uh we're seeing
massive amounts of of you're seeing in
bodybuilding you're seeing a lot of
deaths a lot of issues and are they all
taking steroids to to look like that to
look that rich yeah so for example for
me for example I'm 510 uh
178 pounds
the natural limit for how big someone
can be without using anabolics is not
that much right if if I was 10 pounds
bigger
of muscle same leanness it would be very
hard to achieve that naturally now if
we're talking about someone that has 30
more pounds of muscle there is zero
percent chance they're not on anything
absolutely zero
um the thing is is that to be leaned
have abs and definition veins and to
carry a lot of muscle it's very hard to
do our bodies aren't really wired for it
you can like the the ongoing joke joke
and fitness is that you can either be
very lean or you can be big uh there's
three things you can be natural lean or
big you got to pick two so you can be
big and natural lean and natural but you
can't be like just you know 200 pounds
shredded
um you know unless you're like six three
then you'd be 200 pounds shredded but
like you can't you can't do all three so
what are you natural and lean I'm
natural lean oh I try big I mean see see
like to like women and like everyday
people they'd be like oh [__] you're big
but in the bodybuilding standards they
would be like no no he's small yeah but
that was your goal right it's like the
normal yeah
that was my goal I always you know I
always was more drawn to like having
that sort of movie star look Christian
Bale the leanness the GQ look then this
whole idea of just trying to put on uh a
bunch of signs there's a certain
insecurity right that oftentimes I'm not
saying in all cases but pretty much the
mass majority of them there's a certain
insecurity
to get that big and sacrifice your
health in the process and make it make
it entire life like I mean I have a
friend that is a documentary filmmaker
and he's done uh stuff with some of
these bodybuilders and you know when you
peel back the layers and get down to it
usually starts with a very big
insecurity yeah you're completely right
I know someone and I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna get into holster but I know
somebody who used to be very small as a
kid and that wasn't good enough and then
he he did all that stuff and yeah it
wasn't good and you know what if that's
if that's how you feel when you're
younger totally understand
um that's kind of normal if you feel
like you're bullied and you you want to
kind of build up this muscle and
strength I would say do some boxing do
some Jujitsu and put on a nice natural
amount of muscle don't go down this this
this this this sort of rabbit hole to
like try and be on a bunch of drugs be
that big guy that's kind of puffy
um because in the end if you can't even
know if you don't even know how to throw
a punch you're not going to be that
effective anyway so learn how to kind of
learn some basics in boxing wrestling or
Jiu Jitsu and put on a natural amount of
muscle and you'll feel much better but
the thing is and this is why mindset is
actually so important in in Fitness and
in life in general is because
if you don't evolve you will still
always see yourself as that small person
there are guys that are massive that are
240 pounds that still feel like they
look in the mirror they think they're
tiny they're small and they're insecure
my arms are tiny and that's a very very
bad place to be yeah I've seen it like
yeah I I know I'm like how these people
in my head and I'm like yeah like I know
somebody I said to me you're too big and
he's like no I have to get bigger and
I'm like don't like you look weird like
don't do it yeah it's it's ridiculous
but you're known for this you know
Hollywood celebrity physique you
mentioned Christian Bale so how do you
get that is it diet is it exercise is it
supplements I know obviously you have
the Kino supplements so how do you get
it diet exercise supplements what is
that so one of the things I did in
Fitness when I really started to
percolate in the industry is I basically
simplified everything anyone watching if
you've stayed you paid attention to
Fitness scene
a lot of people feel like this is so
complicated okay I don't get it like fat
loss is XYZ I do all these different
workouts some people are telling me
don't eat carbs eat carbs eat once a day
eat five times a day everyone's made it
so complicated ultimately to have a
great physique you need two things okay
you need to have like a good amount of
muscle in the right proportion and you
need and you need to have a low level
body fat so that's the first to
understand okay that's what built a
great physique is it's a good amount of
muscle with low levels of body fat okay
so how do we actually achieve the muscle
muscle is simply is is nothing more than
a byproduct of strength the reason why
someone has a good amount of muscles
because they're strong and so the focus
with training needs to be on increasing
strength there's a lot of confusion in
in in in training but ultimately what we
do know without a shred of Doubt is that
we want to be lifting heavier weights
over time okay
um and funny enough a lot of people
don't even emphasize this they they have
these five day six day a week routine
means two hours in the gym just doing
lots and lots of reps and they plateau
in order to build muscle we must get
stronger okay and so I actually find
lifting three days a week and right now
I'm only doing twice but when I left
three days a week very very focused push
hard I'm better able to produce strength
gains as a natural that being in the gym
all the time so the first thing is you
want to get stronger on key lifts for
example you want to build your chest you
know incline bench flat bench press you
want to build a bigger back biceps
weighted chin UPS shoulder press Etc
squats deadlifts or Bulgarian split
squats Romanian deadlifts if you get
stronger on the key movements for your
physique
um you will gain muscle now as far as
leanness is concerned fat loss is
nothing more than essentially calorie
deficit while maintaining muscle so
correct amount of protein and being a
calorie deficit and your body will strip
off fat now you can do that eating six
times a day you can eat it do that
eating twice a day you can have carbs
eat less carbs it's really up to you my
sort of thesis on Fitness was that but
the key to getting lean is to make
eating at a caloric deficit as easy as
possible once I created that lens that's
when fat loss became easy how do I yeah
if I am burning 2700 calories a day as a
man moderately active how do I make
eating
2200 2300 as easy as possible I can do
it every day because I was not the
person that like fat loss was easy I
love eating I can eat more than anyone I
go to dinner I could eat two dinners I
love cookies I love it all okay some
people just like oh I don't need dessert
I love it all okay steak potatoes
cookies dessert and so me cutting back
on food it's never been easy even my
father was like loved you know he would
eat everything like he had a big
appetite
um so for me it was like how do I
actually make this something I can stick
to and that's when I created my little
little different meal plan and
strategies to make being a deficit as
easy as possible now
this is like one of the most important
things because there are lots of people
that work out they go to the gym they
have some muscle but it's covered in a
layer of body fat and when you see some
of these guys on the movie screen not
all of them are massive like Brad Pitt
the reason he looks so good is he's got
some muscle but he's got a very low body
fat and that's when his jawline pops and
his abs are just chiseled your physique
changes when you get to like the top
level of leanness right and you don't
want to get too lean if you get too lean
there can be drops in testosterone
because your body's wired for survival
but if you get to like eight to ten
percent your body changes your shoulders
become more sculpted your waist becomes
more taut and you get that more that
Sleek proportion your chest appears more
like a plate of armor less droopy
um so when you get lean that's when you
really separate from the pack that's
when you stand out and that was my folks
in Fitness a lot of guys that work out
they have some muscle but how do we
separate from the Pack the movie actors
they're separating from the pack there's
a reason why if uh uh studio is gonna
risk hundreds of millions of dollars on
a movie they're picking the guy that has
that lean chisel physique not that sort
of
big puffier guy
what about with women because I know
it's I I mean I think it's harder for
women to lose fat like we hold fat more
um and then so yeah what about fat with
women and then also is it the same with
building muscle like you have to just
keep increasing the weight you can't
just keep it at a at a at a right yeah
um okay so one so the reason fat loss is
harder for women is
um women on average are smaller right
the smaller you are the less calories
you're gonna burn so women naturally
don't burn as much if a woman's
maintains calories is eight is eighteen
hundred for her to lose a pound a week
it's only like 1300 calories whereas a
guy that's bigger and and moderately
active his maintenance might be three
thousand he might be able to lose a
pound a week on 2500 and so the more
calories you burn every day the smaller
percentage uh of a like of a deficit you
need to lose that pound of fat a week so
women have it harder
um in that sense and they're also more
sensitive to to being in a calorie
deficit so obviously for for women like
reproduction is very very important and
so if you're in too much of a calorie
deficit for too long uh you your
hormones can get a whack you might not
even be able to get pregnant and so
women when they're in too much of a
deficit uh it feels harder it's more
uncomfortable whereas a guy can tend can
can handle it a little bit better
um so for women that is harder the same
thing holds true though like for a woman
to lose body fat they need to be in a
calorie deficit it's just harder and
it's easier to screw up because if a guy
eats an extra 500 calories okay maybe
he's at maintenance now like you know
but for a Girl Like a few hundred more
calories can just throw her off yeah and
then you know
one bad day of eating a week for a woman
could undo the entire week could even
put them in a surplus yeah so for women
like the thing is is like you just have
to be very very consistent and there's
not much wiggle room there's not much
room to mess up on the weekend I haven't
seen very many women that were able to
like be strict Monday to Friday and then
just go balls the walls on the weekend
and lean down that doesn't really work
for women yeah no that's that's true I
can speak from experience yeah if I like
especially in America the food here is
insane I know and that's the problem is
a woman like you're going out for dinner
and you're getting the same portion as a
six foot 200 pound man you know so you
ha it it it's a look you have to be a
little more careful and it can be
a little trickier to really nail down
I want to talk about
um
so I think the most attractive thing if
is if a man has a wide frame so big
shoulders deltoids whatever it is so
what are some of and I know a lot of
women find it find this attractive to
like that big wider frame so what are
some of the key exercises that a man can
do to make his deltoids bigger and just
have a wider frame generally yeah and so
I also preface and say that one
we have like different research on
universal attraction
um what women are most attracted to in a
man and like top of the list universally
across the globe different cultures is
the shoulder to waist ratio yeah okay so
when you have broader shoulders more of
a taut waist that's a sign of Health
um and that's a sign of like physical
performance so
that is something you want to optimize
for now we're seeing new research that's
actually showing that there's a
clear-cut link between a man's waist to
shoulder ratio and the woman's
satisfaction in the bedroom interesting
yeah and so like the number one thing
okay based on This research I saw and
also Derek my place was sharing this but
uh the number one sign that a woman was
like fully satisfied in the bedroom
okay there's a lot of things that they
could test and it was the shoulder to
the waist ratio wow interesting that is
yeah yeah why is that
um well I'm not I can't speak for women
per se I just imagine that uh that uh
the re like the reason is again like
when a woman is more tracked when a
woman let's ask you actually why do you
think that is what I think what is why
do you think the shoulder waist ratio
makes uh by and large women uh more
satisfied in the bedroom I I don't know
I can't give you like the science but I
can I can understand it if he if he has
like if he has a smaller waist and a
broader shoulders I guess it means he's
extremely fit he's muscly he's healthy
he's strong so he's everything about him
he's just gonna perform better he's
gonna be stronger everything is going to
be stronger and healthier and better as
opposed to a man who's got a little bit
of extra body fat or skinny weak I guess
it's it as you know I can't speak
um as you know the woman who'll have to
speak to this but you know it's a very
very interesting research and I mean it
you know it definitely makes sense
um for a woman obviously if it's going
to be a more exciting experience at the
guy's in top shape if you know Brad Pitt
and Troy is you know in the bedroom with
you it's going to be a lot better than
if uh you know Jonah Hill is is so I
mean those are yeah I don't like that
sorry Jonah we'll get you on the movie
star body program yeah you should oh
yeah but that's see that's an extreme
example and and your reaction made it
clear-cut yeah
um good yeah no so we're so stevens or
Seth Rogen you know whatever I don't
know it doesn't matter how much money
they have yeah yeah so
that is a good that's a very good like
that like see if I you know for the men
listening that's exciting news [__] I
can if I just build the shorter waist
ratio that's going to be way more
exciting for the woman that I'm in love
with yeah you know and it's honestly so
it's not even that hard to do
um simplest thing to do to build your
shoulder waste ratio is one if you have
excess body fat tighten up the calories
500 calorie deficit
um and start to lean up I like to do a
fast every day if this is how I I have a
big appetite this is how I stay in
deficit I fast every day I eat A light
meal around you know lunch time and then
a big dinner feast and then I have
because like I I have like a bit of a
sweet tooth I have my last 400 calories
of whatever I want it could be Oreos it
could be chocolate whatever I want yeah
so I'll finish like 1900 or like 2 000
calories a day of whole food and then
the last 400 is whatever I want every
this isn't once a week this isn't twice
week this is every day wow what did you
have last night
last night I actually was staying in Bal
Harbor at the St Regis and they had like
this the mini bar had some cookies oh
wow I had some I had some they were good
like the mini bar cookies hit different
yeah so I had some I had some cookies
um but so that is the most important
like you must get like if you have
excess body fat you must get lean Jonah
Hill you must nail that deficit probably
got to get on at least 2 000 calories a
day max who needs to hit you up get the
10K steps in I will get you lean uh and
then secondly if I want to simplify the
shoulder waste ratio as simple as
possible weighted Pull-Ups
if you want to start with body weight
that's fine too get strong on weighted
pull-ups I have thousands of men that
have built up to doing literally 90
pound weighted Pull-Ups for five reps 90
pounds attached which is insane
um shoulder presses you can do seated
double shoulder presses getting very
strong I have tons of men that have
built up to doing like 80 90 100 pounds
people don't realize how strong they can
get when they train the right way if you
just get stronger on shoulder presses
and weighted pull-ups you will build a
wider back bigger shoulders and you'll
start to have a bit more of that movie
star physique you do not need to
complicate Fitness like yes you can
follow a full structured routine and
that's the best bet but even if you're
like at home you got a pull-up bar you
got some dumbbells do some pull-ups do
some shoulder presses do a little
fasting be in the right deficit and you
your shoulders and back will start to
like pop out and you'll get lean and
you'll start to carve out that v-shape I
actually did so many like I got so
focused on weighted pull-ups I had to
stop doing them because my back would
get too wide wow can you back never be
too wide so like for me I find it's hard
for me to like get my biceps too big I
find they're a little bit stubborn
um but my back just like when I do
weighted pull-ups my back grows like a
weed wow like and I and I I'm like I'm
like a 42 usually and I want to stay a
42 if I start if I go too hard I'm just
gonna be like it's gonna look it's gonna
be too wide so it's very easy that's a
great problem to have it's a great
problem to have it's amazing it's
actually if you just get strong on
weighted pull-ups okay you can do them
once a week three sets get strong
weighted pull-ups build up to 50 pounds
60 pounds Etc I got up to doing like 120
pounds for four or five reps
um I had to chill if you just get strong
weight of pull-ups you can get your back
as big as you want
that's fascinating that's a great
problem to have yeah so with all of this
in mind
um I want to talk about male depression
um because I saw a statistic the other
day which said that male suicide in the
UK is three times higher than that or
female I don't know what it is here and
I imagine it's pretty similar globally
so I want your take on that do you think
male depression is real or should a man
just push through and mat up as they say
yeah no it's a very very good question
um I I think there's really two sides of
the coin okay on one hand there is an
element of if your dopamine levels are
blunted you've lost a bit of that
dopamine sensitivity doping levels
aren't firing correctly and you've taken
all the sort of the wrong actions then
yes there is that feeling of feeling
depressed where you just do not have
that spark you do not have that
motivation you feel like you're living
in a fog life loses its meaning
the boss drives in front of you
if it hits me who cares
well that's like so that's a real thing
you can literally have that feeling
um but to climb out of it
um
there are certain steps that you can
take and the idea that the idea that you
were just you have depression and it's
genetic and there's nothing you can do
about it that's just what it is is wrong
absolutely you can change it you can fix
it and you know as far as I've seen it's
funny like people are so quick to jump
onto uh to jump onto uh drugs yes and to
get get into that stuff and the research
is really not that conclusive on it if
you dig into it just simply working out
does more than jumping on
antidepressants
um so I it's funny like I see a lot of
people just go to the doctor oh you know
a doctor told me to do this the only
person that's going to care more about
your health is yourself and I think the
highest quality of life is to
um build yourself up strong naturally
and uh I understand like I've had
periods in my life where I actually felt
that depression and it lingered for a
while but there's certain things that
had to change to get out of it like
um so for one I was during the pandemic
right
I uh
I was in this is awesome why I'm happy
to be in Florida but I was in Canada and
we were in lockdown for like it felt
like forever it was like two or three
years lockdown when it was two or three
years
where restaurants were closed gyms were
closed
you couldn't even have people over okay
I mean
I have whoever I wanted okay okay but
you were not supposed to have people
over but we do what we want I'm ain't
paying 50 tax and not having someone
over
but uh
life was very very dark and human beings
there was absolutely no way we're wired
to be an apartment day in day out for
months and months on end
um and so at one point I was working
very hard and I was just kind of I was
on my phone so much right I was on my
phone
uh social media and stuff like that and
I just kind of was wired I wasn't
sleeping well I started taking Edibles I
started taking yeah we eat Edibles every
night just to kind of shut off that was
sort of became a bit of my crutch during
the pandemic and at first I was sleeping
and at first I felt fine and then slowly
over the course of several weeks if not
several months just kind of felt like I
felt different right
felt a little bit of uh felt a little
bit like less sort of excitement
um less like you know fulfillment less
Drive less passion less spark less je ne
sais quoi and then you know and then
uh less creativity too I felt way less
creative
um way less driven and then slowly like
it just got worse and worse and worse
and worse where I just like life lost
its meaning and it's interesting because
we're still working out at the time I
was working out I was working out 100 I
was eating well I was running my
business I was doing certain productive
things I was also kind of a bit isolated
I wasn't in the sun in Miami you know I
wasn't outside that much but I was
definitely taking good steps
um but it's interesting is because for
the last several years marijuana has
been touted as this great thing
legalized marijuana okay you know what I
think like if you want to do it that's
your choice
um but the idea that marijuana is like
all good and not bad is wrong
um and a lot of times the very thing you
go to weed for whether it's anxiety
whether it's bad sleep whether it's
stress
becomes exacerbated so at first it helps
and then all sudden the same issue
becomes worse and worse and worse and
worse and you know not a lot of people
talk about this but marijuana absolutely
blunts your dopamine system where you
become less sensitive to dopamine and
you get less increases in dopamine and
one of the signs of having incredible
mental health and one of the signs of
very very successful people the reason
they're able to work so damn hard is
their doping system is firing correctly
and when you become a stoner you're just
hitting weed weakly it it erodes that
system and your ability to be hyper
incentivized to work very very hard that
work reward pathway gets broken down and
when that's broken down it's so much
harder to become successful and so much
harder to become happy that's why if you
do a little bit of a dopamine reset you
know I remember when I was how do you do
that well well here's one little simple
example when I was like 11 years old I
went to summer camp for a month and it
was like we're in cabins did canoe trips
and Tents and uh you know we didn't have
any technology for a very long time and
it was fun you know it was fun and then
I remember like one day we got to eat
like freaking Corn Pop cereal and watch
uh Austin Powers I've never had more fun
watching a movie and eating Corn Pops in
my life than after like 20 days of like
being in a canoe and camping no
technology and so that's like a simple
extreme example
um but what I recommend people do is
like is try and limit those certain
things whether it's watching a TV show
or movies
um whether it's checking your social
media trying the more time you can spend
truly being present
the better control like you have and and
then the better experiences you'll have
with dopamine so if you're waking up
like checking your social media then
checking every two minutes and then
posting something and checking checking
non-stop you're kind of setting your day
in a bad standard it's harder to get
fulfillment from like real stuff this is
also sort of the Catch-22 with the world
we live in all the technology we have is
very very productive and has great
utility but it also can strip away
fulfillment from life if you're not
careful
yeah no I totally agree with you I hate
social media like I hate it even though
I use it to work and whatever I hate it
but um I agree with you with marijuana I
also hate that because I feel like
something which I think is like my
um my superpower whatever it's like how
fast my brain can go like it can go so
fast you can do a million things I could
think 100 million things at once and
they can go super fast but marijuana it
just like sends me to sleep it sends you
to sleep and it just it it cripples into
like it has a Rippling effect where it's
not just like this little transient
effect it ripples across the next day
the next day yeah it does and it's like
as a man it's it's
these little moves can send you an
upward spiral or a downward spiral right
you start to use marijuana to sleep well
to relax and then you know the next day
you're a bit tired you lost your spark
you don't have the same creativity so
you didn't come up with that awesome
idea you're on the same drive and then
days go past and you're just you're
you're not noticing this downfall which
is and here's the thing is that
sometimes the worst thing in life isn't
something that's just clear-cut
inherently bad it's something that we
kind of think is helping us but over
time it just erodes us because it's much
harder to catch it took me a long time
to actually put the pieces together and
be like holy [__] the reason I'm feeling
absolutely depressed is because of like
one of the big reasons is is this little
edible I'm taking at night I'm not
taking it to be high I'm taking it at 11
PM so I fall asleep in an hour or two
and then you know and then just get back
on my grind
um and so the very very empowering thing
um for the men listening right now is
that there's sort of two things to look
at if you're looking at mental health
and and working through depression right
so one thing you want to live your life
in a way that's gonna uh support your
dopamine system okay that means excise
means proper nutrition right it also
means
um being very you know cognizant like
you know meditation is one of the best
things you can do even doing a you know
even a cold shower in the morning can be
very helpful for that
um you know using you know technology
and social media as a tool not letting
it use you not checking it chronically
the amount of teenagers and 20 year olds
that scroll through Tick Tock for two
three hours four hours straight is
insane it's in it's nuts like I don't
like no wonder you're depressed you're
smoking weed at night you're scrolling
through Tick Tock for three four hours
like this is my this is really my my
question to people it's that of course
you're depressed why wouldn't you be
you're on social media for hours a day
if you were an alien and you know
looking down on human beings you'd be
like
course like what do they do in the
standard piece of plastic for five hours
a day they're not interacting with each
other then and then you know alcohol
weed is all depressant it's it it can
definitely affect your mental health if
you if you you know weed especially use
it on a weekly basis
um so there's all these different things
that can crumble your dopamine system um
so that's one hand now the second hand
is that you have to build a life and
become the person that like you have to
build an inspiring life and build
yourself as a great person that that is
that you know you value if you are not
happy with your life the situation you
live in and the person you are that is
you're probably gonna be depressed
depression isn't inherently a bad thing
nothing is inherently a bad thing
um I actually believe that feeling
depressed is feedback
that your body is giving you telling you
that you're not living up to your
highest values
if you were not depressed that would be
bad if I spent five hours a day
scrolling Tick Tock mindlessly and
smoking weed and drinking and doing
nothing with my day if I did not feel
depressed that would be very very bad
because now I'd continue going down that
road so you actually don't want to like
freak out I'm depressed and this is
horrible horrible thing no this is a
sign that the way you're living a life
is not in accordance with your highest
values and then certain behaviors are
doing are blunting and disrupting your
doping system so when you move those out
of the way where your doping system can
fire correctly and then when you start
to set real goals toward and work
towards goals that you actually care
about look we all have different values
right some per someone might never care
about making millions of dollars a year
but for them they want to do some cool
traveling maybe even do the canoe trips
they want to do if you live according to
your highest values and you take care of
like your yourself you will feel very
very good I haven't met anyone that
actually started to take real action and
do these steps and that was like no I
still feel depressed I haven't seen it
so this leads me on to my next topic
which is freedom of speech right yeah
and I know you've been sort of like
toeing that line a little bit
um and the reason why I feel this is
connected is because what you're saying
is really amazing like it's really
useful information and you know you go
to a doctor and they just give you pills
right like they don't they don't want to
actually help you
um and I've noticed that a lot of
content right now is being Shadow banned
um have you felt that any of your
content has been restricted in any way
censored Shadow fans uh the main thing
that definitely uh will get restricted
is anything around
um the pandemic kind of thing that stuff
so that absolutely restricted
um everything else that I've said so far
has been pretty it's pretty open sesame
um because I've noticed that a lot of
self um a lot of male self-improvement
content is being taken down so I want to
get your thoughts on that yeah I think
I've been doing content for a very very
long time since I was 19 years old I
I've have so many years and years of of
content that um I feel like there's a
little bit of a wiggle room for me and
uh but I've been okay as far as as far
as that
um but absolutely there's certain things
I could talk about that definitely uh
wouldn't wouldn't uh stay online too
long like what do you want to talk about
that you can't talk about I you know if
anyone watches my stories they'll see
firsthand that like my thoughts on on
the lockdown my thoughts on on some of
these things
um you know I I it was we were living in
a Truman Show it was ridiculous for the
two years it was the rules you know you
walk into a restaurant you gotta put
your mask on you sit down you take it
off like
it was insane
um and you know the funny part was just
how willing people were just to comply
very few people were like this is
[__] so dumb this is the stupidest
thing I've ever and funny enough in
Canada for example there isn't as much
of a
connection
a deep hard connection to freedom and
keeping the government in check yeah in
Canada there's more of this blind trust
why would the government do anything why
would they do that why would they want
to you know restrict our free you know
they're just looking out for us this is
blind trust in the government that by
and large Canadians have obviously not
all of them have because there were some
very very strong men that stood up
against it so we do in Canada yeah we
love them yeah we do have some very
strong men that actually see different
but by and large you know Canadians do
not have this strong sense of
um of Freedom
um and that's also why like for example
like someone like Jordan Peterson really
skyrocketed skyrocketed um years and
years ago when he was uh when he was
wholeheartedly against one of these
different bills that they were trying to
pass that would the transgender bill
yeah it was a compelled speech where you
have to use certain speech by law
um like literally by law so
so uh yeah Canadians need to understand
something very very simple history
repeats itself and when you know
people and how they have too much power
like things can get very very bad you
never want to give someone unlimited
power too much power
um and that's also that's also what we
saw you know right you know because
things can
happen slowly they don't just go all out
day one they push the line they reel it
back in they push there's a certain
process to take away your freedom
um and that's why like you know at first
like oh don't worry it's a little bit of
a lockdown no one thought we'd be
wearing masks for two years it didn't
cross anyone's mind and smart people it
did yeah yeah
the smart people saw it coming yeah and
then it just it just kind of one little
thing okay fine just two weeks they make
you let up a little bit okay and then
and then you agree you kind of acquiesce
you reluctantly agree and then it's a
bit more and there's a bit more and then
if you if they were to tell you what
they're gonna do day one you would have
been like [__] no
but they slowly reel you in it's a very
manipulative tactic
um and so Canadians must understand if
you had your eyes open and you weren't
living in a cave that you we need to
keep the government absolutely in check
British people are the same we don't we
don't have that freedom spirit that the
Americans have
um but it's interesting because when you
were speaking about it I can tell you're
like a little bit uncomfortable to say
certain things like at the beginning
you're like oh what's she gonna ask me
oh no do I I'm gonna say anything trust
me I I I no I I a thousand percent it is
very no you stand by it but yeah the
idea that you can just say anything
unfiltered
it's very hard to do these days yeah
well I want that like I want to live in
a world where we can say anything online
and I mean online because online really
is where you can't actually say things
like you'll get like I had I had a
podcast taken down I was talking about
um yes the the pandemic I was trying to
use like fancy words like Jib Jab yeah
well in my garage you came up with
JibJab and eleven nine and all that you
know what though I know my followers
very well because I do stories I can I
can read stuff they freaking love it
when I push the limits they want it more
they lately they are into it that's good
because that's that's what I want and I
know my followers love it too and you
know I want to live in a world where we
can say what we want to say and the
thing that I'm noticing is nobody's
pushing for this the only the only
um project or if you want to call it a
project that I know creating sort of
like a platform that allows us to speak
freely it's called Tommy net have you
heard of them no no so they're creating
like this decentralized internet where
anyone in the world can basically say
can access the internet and I know that
in China and North Korea there's so much
um there's so much um like government
restriction like they can't access the
internet so would you like to talk more
about these sorts of things and would
you like to reach a greater audience you
know like people in China and like
people in North Korea and actually say
whatever you want to say yes absolutely
um now there is a little bit of a
blessing disguise because
it's harder to speak with absolute like
unstifled
um if you are willing to push the limit
and
be say things most people aren't want to
say it's a lot easier to Garner an
audience yes that's very true because
people are literally just they're
waiting for someone to say like what
they feel they're just please so if you
can kind of push the envelope and and be
brave and just freaking you know I'm
just gonna say it then people respect
that so much and also if you're the kind
of person that's tiptoeing and oh you
know you know going with whatever the
Matrix is you know as it's called now uh
credit where credit's due yeah uh but
for the people that are just buckling
out of The Matrix
like you know little [__] then
you lose respect and we're seeing that
with Logan Paul right yes he's losing a
lot of freaking respect because he is
buckled onto the Matrix and he's like he
always doesn't want to upset you know
the big hand and uh you know he's
turning his comments off videos you know
so unbelievable so it's it's a
double-edged sword even though the
landscape is not good right now
if you want to have some balls
it though you get censored yeah I know
that's the that's the that's the tough
part you do get censored but if you can
tow the line but you know what I do
think by and large I think right now
there's a bit of a shift things are
shifting in a New Direction
um and because you know what's funny is
that like
a couple years ago it didn't seem like
there there was as many voices saying
this stuff as there are now
well I feel like people like Elon Musk
are really helpful yeah so Elon Musk
obviously you know CEO of Twitter I'm on
Twitter and I'm there like as soon as he
took over I'm there like crazy like it
was fake it was bad for you you know all
this stuff yeah yeah oh I'm going crazy
you haven't seen it okay sweet yeah yeah
oh I'm like you know what Twitter you
gotta get it I gotta get on Twitter I
never use Twitter I do think like I'm
very bullish on Twitter with Elon
running it and I think it's gonna be
very very good and and I think like I'm
I do a lot of stuff on Instagram I just
don't know if Facebook is gonna be like
I think I see more of a positive future
for Twitter so I have to get on Twitter
that's awesome there's only two genders
men can't get pregnant
and you're not you're not getting
canceled no we're not getting death
threats but here's the problem like I
love that what Elon Musk is doing but I
truly believe and maybe I'm just being
cynical but I do believe that all humans
are not all humans most humans are
corruptable
um and I think it's dangerous to leave
our trust in freedom of speech I'll try
so freedom speech in Elon musk's hands
so that's why I'm obviously I you know
my main thing is like crypto that's why
I'm so excited about web3 things like
Tommy browser Tommy net like I just want
to see that take off I gotta talk to you
more about this stuff well would you
ever use would you use a decentralized
platform like Tommy net
um yeah you would yeah I gotta look into
this I haven't even heard of Tommy nut
but yeah it's totally decentralized
anyone anywhere in the world can access
it
um there's no there's no Co there's no
centralized Authority
um nobody can say oh that's bad take it
down I know because that's the challenge
is that um you know many many people are
investing that years and years and years
and tons of money building an audience a
brand on a platform and it gets and and
without really any clear-cut rules or or
instructions it's getting just pulled
for them for really no reason yeah um
and that is really really you know
that's really freaking messed up
um and I've seen it happen you know I've
seen it happen uh many many times even
years ago I've seen I've seen guys go
we'll get wiped off
um but I have never seen more of a
strong push yes on some of these
elements like I think there is you know
for every reaction there's an equal
opposite reaction and I think we're
seeing that right now
um but again like it's it's it's pretty
pretty
pretty still kind of hard to just speak
all out well one of the topics that you
can't talk about which we're going to
get into now is men and women okay so I
know that you talk about stuff a little
bit
um you're like yeah of course I do yeah
I know what I'm doing so let's hear it
so okay you talk about you know how a
man should be on a date you know what he
should wear what he should do how he
should behave so I'm really interested
to know like what is Greg like on a date
like how does Greg behave and then
obviously people can learn from you and
take advice from you
um yeah what's Greg's uh like with women
if if you're going on a date as a man
with a woman like there's certain things
that guys do wrong
um that that uh that is not attractive
um so one you know the main thing is
really to be confident obviously you
have to be confident and what is
confidence confidence is nothing more
than just comforting yourself now if
you're going on the first date you've
gone on in in six months you're gonna be
nervous
um you're gonna it's it's you know it's
harder to be confident but as you you
know put yourself out there you start to
build that skill set um but the first
thing is to really be confident which is
comfort in yourself
um and really to lead women if you talk
to any woman they want
someone to lead them they don't want you
to ask them like hey like would you want
to go to dinner sometime you know or hey
where do you want to go to dinner and a
lot of guys don't have strong like role
models on like how to actually like what
to actually do but you want to be more
like you want to lead
um as like if you're inviting a girl out
you want to like you know plan eight
pick you up eight pm perfect X Y and Z
and then uh and then on the date
um you know I I uh you know I it's it's
easier if you ask me a very very
specific question but um the main thing
I find is that it's very very important
to not talk about yourself too much okay
because a lot of guys think they need to
impress a girl they have a beautiful
girl on a date and they're like man like
I really got to get this girl like me so
like what are the cool things I can talk
about and they just try and impress her
oh you know I'm gonna I'm gonna you know
reference like this job thing and
they're they're just trying to find all
these different beats to impress the
girl and then women are very very smart
and they can pick up on things at a much
higher uh social level they can see
through it they can see absolutely
through it and so it's better to
actually
learn about the girl ask the woman that
you're on a date with questions learn
about her where is she from I mean one
of the worst advice uh one of the worst
pieces of advice in dating is in the is
in the pickup industry which is don't be
the interview guy don't ask question
question they tell you not to do that
they tell you not today like the pickup
artist game okay and you're saying do
that I'm saying do it interview her I'm
telling you absolutely
if you interview her you why because
again like if you're actually a high
value man then you don't just see pretty
like beautiful girl oh my God she's
perfect that's it game over you gotta
ask for questions and learn about her
well that's one reason but if you don't
ask her questions and you end up kind of
talking about yourself telling stories
maybe you even sound Charming maybe even
sound cool
um the whole time she's gonna just be
like wow this guy's just obsessed with
himself he doesn't know anything about
me and then you start to show her
interest you start to show her interest
oh you know I want to see you again or
you try and go for a kiss she's gonna be
thinking why even into me
that is so true I feel like he doesn't
know anything about me why does he like
me why does he like me yeah yeah and
then and then all of a sudden the
woman's gonna think about reasons why
she should not be with you
I'll be insulted yeah I've been insulted
exactly exactly so as a man what you
want to do is just let go of this whole
pressure that you have to impress her
that you got to be really really cool
and and uh is that in it of itself is
unattractive worry more just about being
a little more mysterious and secondly
find out a lot about her and again you
might be on a date with a girl and after
an hour you might be like
we're not going to get along at least
you know right at least you know
um but but you know more likely you're
gonna be like okay wow like she's got
some really cool stuff that I really
really like I really appreciate this
about her and now the connection or your
interest in her is going to be so much
more believable and so much more
authentic
um and uh you know
and there's some like there's some like
cool stuff there but but again women are
not going to complain after a date to
their friends saying like he just asked
me a bunch of questions I just talked
about myself no woman has ever said I
had the worst state ever I just talked
about myself the whole time what they
will say is I had the worst date ever he
just talked about himself the whole time
he didn't ask me anything so if you
actually want to build a connection you
want to learn about her a lot and yes
like it will be thrown back on you when
you ask you a whole bunch of questions
she should make oh my God I'm talking
about me my whole time what about you
when a girl says that she is into you oh
wow she is sold when she's like we've
been talking about me the whole time
like what about you what about this I
feel like
they said that before you know and even
like if you want to play the game a bit
more on a date as a guy you can kind of
in the beginning be a little bit
aloof
slightly cold you know you meet her
shake her hand no sorry sorry sorry you
meet her you give her a hug whatever
sorry you give her a hug you say hi you
know nice to meet you sit down and then
just be a little bit not when I say
shake your hand hug or whatever
um hold like pull hold back a little bit
okay A lot of guys that see a girl
they're really into really beautiful
they're like on a silver platter they're
leaving leading forward oh my God you
know and then just they're just like
honest of a platter for hold it back a
little bit
and then as she starts to open up as you
ask more questions as you start to learn
more about her then you can give her a
little bit more and then the woman's
gonna feel like more like wow she had
she had to she had to earn your
attention earn your interest it wasn't
just guaranteed off the start of the day
and then she's gonna it's gonna feel a
lot better
um and then again
as a man like the number one thing you
have to use right is your attention so
if you're on a date yeah attention your
attention attention if we're on a date
okay and you know we're chatting I'm
asking a question then you've got your
phone you're checking your phone right
here you're being a little bit off
the last thing I'm going to do is be
like just talking while you're I would
never ever talk while you're on your
phone okay cool so what about that I
just I would sit back and I would just
wait for you to kind of realize well I
do that with friends anyway yeah because
I find it really disrespectful so if
like if you're if someone's like talking
to me and they're on their phone I'm
gonna wait until they're done right
right and then I'll no it's smart and
the other thing for men to understand is
that women can be very very different
certain women like different things
right
um and so if you make the wrong move
like one move a one woman might love it
Laura and then Jennifer doesn't like it
give me an example
um okay let's say for example like if
like some women are more down to hook up
sooner and some women need a bit more
time a bit more investment right
um and so if you could understand more
and more about a girl and and uh and
learn about her you can understand sort
of her blueprint and then you know what
she's gonna respond the best too
you know what about um what a man should
wear okay let's see um yeah very I think
for a first date
um be very very simple right
um
nice dark jeans now it's less about like
really fitted tighter jeans more about
like more medium fitted jeans
um I like to wear dark jeans uh boots
and a well-fitting t-shirt that's it
like simple is fine I mean you can wear
if it's a nicer place you can wear a
button-down shirt but
I think for men the key with fashion for
men is Simply Having uniforms for
different settings you want to have
different uniforms so
um for the gym you know simple you know
joggers t-shirt etc for your work you
got your work outfit the idea that you
have to have all these different outfits
and different clothes I'm going to mix
this up is like wrong and your masculine
energy is more of a consistent thing you
know if you look at uh Elon Musk you
look at some of these different guys
they kind of wear the same thing if you
watch the show called californiacation
Hank Moody he wears blue jeans and a
black T-shirt like he's got a daily
uniform Vincent Chase like same thing
daily uniform you just want to find sort
of your daily uniform and then that
frees up so much time
yeah I think you agree yeah I think I
think dog jeans and a black T-shirt dark
jeans and a black T-shirt and let your
personality let your V shape yes
let your physique speak for itself
um and let the woman have fun dressing
up and and having more variety yeah it's
true and I think behaviors is like so
important like you're right leading
um and women we don't mean to like [__]
test but like we will well I personally
will just like pause and watch him
navigate and see if he can navigate
you see what I mean right does that make
sense yeah yeah yes yes yes because like
I'm very I'm like a very competent
person
um but like in in that kind of scenario
I'm like no no I'm I'm very like laid
back you know I'm very submissive you
want to be in your feminine and you want
to make sure that that guy can allow you
to stay in your feminine so I'm watching
somewhere watching him navigate and I'm
seeing how he handles things and that's
the thing is that most women are gonna
be their happiest when they're able to
especially on a date or with a romantic
partner or potential Suitor they're
going to be happiest when they feel like
they can just let go and be their
feminine yeah when they feel like the
guy is like freaking if you guys drive I
don't know where to park or where do I
park you know go here or you know where
should we sit or you know when the when
the guy isn't like leading strong and
certainly and with confidence uh then
the woman can't be in her feminine and
then she's in you know then she has to
shift into her masculine and it's uh
that's there is very little chance for
attraction and seduction to take place
when she can't let go yeah no that's
spot on and then another really
controversial thing which you'll like
not allowed to talk about is um like the
man and the woman's role you have kind
of touched on it a bit but what's your
take are men and women equal you know
should a man be the one who's dealing
with all the hassle is it good for a
woman to just not deal with any of the
hassles shouldn't be working she should
just be like creating a beautiful home
with the kids like what's your take on
the gender roles got it yeah well I mean
I think that like you know we're all
individuals so we can all pick whatever
we want to do
um ultimately I think that a lot of
times these more roles that were
developed and built naturally because it
was meant to be the other way it would
have been the other way right so that
there's a certain bias or tendency for
men to fit in certain roles and women to
fit in certain roles
um but I
I uh what's the exact question by the
way like what do I think about it I
Believe In traditional gender roles do I
I like them okay yeah I do I think that
um
when you get like the most strong
connection and you also get like the one
plus one is three when you both sort of
delegate different tasks
right
um so for me for example like in a
relationship like I wanna
be in charge of certain things I want to
focus on you know Building Wealth
etc etc
and then uh and then have the woman uh
more involved in some of the home stuff
but the challenge is right the
challenges is that
50 years ago a man on average could work
the woman could stay at home and they
could buy a house have two cars pay for
groceries uh afford to have children and
that is not the case anymore yeah so the
challenge right now is that even in like
I'm from Toronto even Toronto the idea
that a even above average man can buy a
home have a wife that stays at home and
raise kids it's not a thing anymore it's
literally not a thing you have to make
so much freaking money to actually like
have a family now and inflations become
insane
um and so it's it's uh it's like people
are a lot of people are met like it's a
tough position so my response to that is
um
it's never been easier to be an
entrepreneur and make money right got it
got it the problem is in my opinion is
you're totally right but like the world
has evolved yeah but we haven't taught
anybody this new world like nobody knows
how to make money in this new world
because like we don't teach it we're
still we're still teaching the blueprint
of the 50s and that doesn't work there's
a new blueprint to making money and this
includes making money online from
anywhere in the world and part of this
new blueprint for making money online is
cryptocurrency so one blockchain I want
to tell you about is aquarium because
corium is working to help businesses
move into the online crypto space
corium's Leo on blockchain offers secure
transactions it keeps business
information safe and also reduces
overhead costs for businesses one
feature that allows it to do this is the
advanced minting feature this includes
permissioned minting whitelisting
minting quotas and limits
multi-signature approval audibility and
transparency among many other things
this allows business to operate as
efficiently as possible it also helps
the business simplify the operations
save money and find new ways to scale
with blockchain and cryptocurrencies
increasingly being adopted it's
important that you read up so you don't
get left behind I'll leave more
information for you in the description
below now let's get back to Greg we're
teaching
of the 50
. in any case the uh uh you know parado
principle holds true it's still going to
be like a subset of men that end up
having a lot of financial power and most
men are gonna naturally be
disenfranchised and one of the things if
you go back thousands of years there you
know what's funny is that only a subset
of men's genes pass through most men
their genes were extinguished women most
women became pregnant so basically a
small number of men
impregnated a lot of women right and so
what someone could argue is that this
new landscape where now it's so damn
hard to have a family as a man or even
like you know two people have to work
full time to maybe kind of straight by
and have kids so what's going to happen
now are men going to start having like
three girls like Rich the top ten
percent gonna start having three
they are what do you think about it
um well you know what it's like you know
I mean hey I don't judge but um what do
you think
what do you think is that something you
would do you know this whole like high
value man he can have like three wives
or he can have his main woman and he can
have side women that like she knows
about but as long as she doesn't see
it's fine like is that something you
would do uh you know the Andrew Tate
lifestyle without getting going to jail
understood
um
you know I don't I don't know okay no uh
yeah I don't I know it's uh hmm
like have one girl and have fun on the
side or like have like multiple baby
mamas no like get married and have a
wife
and then you want a boys trip right
right uh you know I'll have to think
about that one but you know what my my
father he had he married my mother he
had five kids and a beautiful family and
uh and I kind of want to follow in those
footsteps and uh you know have kids uh
woman that I love
um right now I got a few little goals to
tackle first so you know but um
but yeah you know what it's uh
that's it's it's I haven't I haven't
like closed the case on that one so I'll
have to you know but again like that is
kind of what's Happening yes it is
what's happening where most men kind of
feel a bit disenfranchised and you see
you see the results on for example on
Tinder and and Bumble and hinge where
where a small minority of men are
getting a lot of the interest
um but as a man the good news is yes
build yourself up you can freaking build
a movie star worthy body you can start
to take action your life set goals build
the income I mean look my goal was not
to make millions of dollars my goal is I
want to make a good income I get a nice
place cool car and have freedom and do
what I love and uh you know and and live
where I wanted to live that's also one
of the things that I cared about it's
funny like I actually saw the Matrix
when I was 19 years old I saw the I saw
like and I also read this book by Tim
Ferriss four-hour work week but a lot of
these seeds were planted I saw the path
in University to work a job end up here
you work you end up if you're lucky you
go up the corporate ladder in your 30s
working all the time making it somewhat
decent income
um and so I was like you know what I'd
rather build something online I can live
where I want to live I have more freedom
and I'm doing what I love and if I want
to turn my computer off one day the
money still comes in and so that's
really what I strove for and then the
more money was more of a byproduct of
just doing I loved and creating tons of
value it wasn't necessarily my first
sort of goal well you've done amazing
um you've done incredibly well and I'm
super excited to see what you do next
where can people follow all your stuff
you know see what you're doing learn
from you
you're on YouTube Instagram how do
people get in touch with you yes um so
I'm very active on Instagram at grego
Gallagher
um as well my website is kinobody.com
k-i-n-o-body.com
uh Kino actually means movie movie body
and that's where you can check out my
programs and uh my Kino Mojo we're
actually having we've had a few guys
that send in their blood work before and
after we've had guys increase their free
testosterone 60 we had one guy just
posted today which was insane anomaly
more than doubled his free testoster
which is crazy but we're seeing
tremendous results on it um but that's
my stuff Gregory algar on Instagram and
kinobody.com Amazing Greg I want to
thank you so much for coming on the show
it's been so interesting learning from
you
um and hearing your opinion on
everything that's that's going on that
was fun to hear and learning from you in
terms of dating and fitness and
everything so thank you so much for
coming on thank you
thanks so much for watching if you like
this kind of content then hit the like
button and subscribe and we'll bring so
much more to you we'll see you all next
week